sí bueno en papel es el más poderoso
acabamos de publicar un artículo del
wall street pero esta noche sobre
exactamente este mismo tema
verdaderamente en cubano no existe una
autoridad constitucional como tal la
figura en papel es miguel díaz canel
pero la realidad es que en cuba gobierna
la familia castro y el resto del partido
y el gobierno siguen sus directrices la
persona más poderosa hoy por hoy en cuba
no es ni raúl castro ni miguel díaz
canel es la familia castro y
específicamente el general luis alberto
rodríguez lópez callejas que es el yerno
externo de raúl castro es el padre de
los nietos de revol castro y es él el
empresario y general que precede por el
preside por encima de un conglomerado
empresarial que se llama gaesa que
controla 75 por ciento de la economía
cubana incluyendo hoteles
las cajas de cambio de todo tipo de
hoteles empresas de construcción o sea
verdaderamente casi toda la economía
cubana está bajo su comando incluso acá
en los eeuu en el congreso su testimonio
de parte del departamento de estado
hacia el congreso poniendo lo hace los
soldados bajo el comando de lope
callejas como los que estaban
directamente vinculados en el
narcotráfico desde el venezuela sí que
es una persona que yo diría más bien es
como una especie de putin cubano y díaz
que vendría siendo como el medio cubano
o sea hay mucho más atrás de lo que se
lo que se pone en pantalla lo que pasa
es que la familia castro ha estado
siendo un papel de tratar de poner a
estos digamos ejecutivos de segundo
nivel al frente para tratar de dar una
pantalla frente al mundo que le permita
el narrativo de que en cuba hay un
cambio lento dentro de la democracia y
de esa forma pedir que se levanten las
sanciones económicas sin duda hay un
cambio pero no es el que estamos viendo
en el partido como está en este fin de
semana sino que estamos viendo en las
calles
en las protestas cada vez crece más el
grupo de artistas del movimiento san
isidro se ha convertido en un dolor de
cabeza diario para el régimen en la
policía ha tenido que huir de las
protestas y manifestaciones cosas que
nunca había sucedido en cuba antes y
cuando vemos el escenario creemos que el
gobierno cubano en este momento enfrenta
la peor crisis económica que ha tenido
desde el colapso de la unión soviética
cuando haya ocurrido en esa época el
gobierno tuvo que eliminar algunos
generales que competían por poder y
aplastar grandes revueltas populares en
las calles pero en aquel momento
contaban con un fidel castro con unos 60
años de edad todos sus colegas eran
personas de es más o menos de 60 años de
edad hoy en día eso es con lo que
existía todavía algo de ideología
comunista socialista dentro de sus
tropas hoy en día todas esas personas
están cerca de los 90 años de edad ya no
existe una gran cantidad de ideología en
mis más muy pocos niveles de el gobierno
cubano lo que quiere decir como alguien
dijo una vez
aquí ya no existe revolución lo que
queda es dictadura y la la pregunta es
qué tanto tiempo podrán aguantar
en este escenario actual que tiene
marcel felipe muchísimas gracias por
estos minutos con france en 24